uh what's on time time with a lot of
cursing got on here like oh god oh [ __ ]
that pretty eyes what and you just
believed her you should have put her out
of her misery right thing I'm not
working for anyone oh [ __ ] great [ __ ]
shooter everybody just calmly actually
shot at age 75 okay I'm not working for
anyone oh I don't know what you're
talking about I just need help we got a
doctor right here okay he'll have a look
okay what the hell is wrong with you
people ok she his hair is perfect don't
get her breasts are pretty good too
don't [ __ ] stored away she survived
out here on her own why are we arguing
about this had a magical Oh Xavier pour
down Antonio Banderas oh yeah Xavier
surely their welfare he'll trust my
flannel go ahead he's a doctor oh ok ok
I couldn't tell from the silly shirt he
was wearing um oh oh oh oh [ __ ] my
[ __ ] arm oh you like it like it like
it oh yeah oh yeah I am never it was you
got you oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah dad
at that isn't how we do things man nicer
bit you get put down oh yeah I'm not
going through this again thank you gotta
ask them that you gotta put her down I
yes uh yeah yeah okay I know that work
for a cousin down an angel oh yeah it
doesn't work bench do any good you'll
just be making it worse for the girl
it's crazy no one's gonna volunteer to
do that I would
being saving her life then what how
would we know it worked just let Carlos
have a look first uh sad i SAT eyes give
her the eyes uh-huh falling for that
[ __ ] little girl if it was up to me you
oh my god has [ __ ] up Oh who's that
[ __ ] Sarah what I say stands get cat
out oh I hate that [ __ ] we're back here
now huh I don't mean to be any trouble I
just want to stop the bleeding and then
I'll go okay i got i'll never see me
again I promise and where exactly would
you go to die today to find help
somewhere else I can up to me girl I
want nothing yes I can badge so what do
you think was it alert her I'll find
like that could be anything I've been a
one way to find out jelly task wait oh
sorry tomorrow morning if the fever set
in we'll know if she's gonna turn in the
meantime we can lock her in the [ __ ]
okay Ted can give me a volcano what
about my arm it needs to get cleaned and
stitched and bandaged girl this impacts
shape Carlos we have all that stuff
inside the cabin we could probably get
bout it please but yeah okay I'm always
I like Albert it turns out you're
telling the truth I'll clean it stitch
it up for you in the morning my man
a lot of [ __ ] my throat Oh see my gonna
get okay finger off the trigger son
ain't your son don't be like that man
it's all right boys got his mom's temper
come on Shay's s you know like it just
goes to show it was a dog you'll see I
guess we'll find out in the morning oh
dear I last that long maybe you could go
look for it I wish I could I really do
but it's too risky sorry and I guess
that's my new home now that's a little
bigger than my last place now so I can
planning it ok so I get bit by a dog a
nap tree like a dog please tell me what
football to eat out of that she's like
that so tired of sleeping in the
doghouse oh I been bugging me on loan
then and they can unbuckle because it
take for this way ok I can't believe
this yeah
right now I can't this down where this
give me some [ __ ] food oh wait they
don't always want a lurker ok let's go
searches barrel for like some seaweed or
something to eat that [ __ ] in here shut
the [ __ ] homeless y'all right now
let's look at life preserver a very cute
decoration had like to feel like him
with a [ __ ] ok anchor not very cute
very cute it's like that I like that
very good and very nice decorating I
have to get commend them let me start to
talk about see you back in there you go
fishing in here this is home to water
coming in yeah not much left in here oh
good good just that excuse if I have to
I can use this / stitches should i guess
i'm at the clean stitch here that's
gonna be insane but alright um let's pry
the sport off you know like let's just
do some damage I'm locked in here like
oh yes okay okay now I pull a little bit
oh no no too weak I'm just a little
nine-year-old girl I forgot ah let's see
here oh yeah so look at this price oh
god this is be great to put my arm in
yes yeah yes okay uh yeah oh let's get
that hammer um I'll [ __ ] I'm to wake up
to a way to forgot okay well what if we
were to let's say
now oh we unfold this get the hand where
take also pry the wall and now let us
see what they come for that you and Alec
in others no rush you know I mean here
all night you know reminds my comfy I
got this [ __ ] right here I'm a tomboy
what's out yeah i said i looked at broke
some more [ __ ] now we're at a wrong
we're on a roll okay okay Oh where's
that hammer it out um left it got good
my trusty hammer good God good now I
grabbed this Beth right haircut get ok
and now we just held a samurai but she
was like you know I cute I got a cue
this up yes baby ok good got a nice
little hole to get out of fianya that
this breaks and worship yeah hate the
hate this second get out of here no
should we stated there now they're going
to [ __ ] one try and kill us does that
think we're doing there
mmm yes any man was here and yeah
options I don't get into [ __ ] Trouble
if I can I guess I'm crawling out of
here let's just get the one dirtier in
the rain you know that it is sleeping it
off that [ __ ] [ __ ] okay I'm just going
to stitch in they come back right oh I
can ask that Walker for help I guess oh
did a needle peroxide in some bandages
okay well I'm not trying to be here and
I could be here and not gonna knock on
the window that's all [ __ ] up now
there's got to be a better way okay oh
yes yes let's not be a patient yet so
you can get underneath the house and
come up like look at me just a little
Mole ticker you know just a little Mole
girl see this is what we're doing we're
going through here we're gonna we're
going to get out of here UK oh good good
very good yes let's use your hands
before using a hammer nothing like that
count one on my love [ __ ] those are a
bunch of dogs on there try to give me an
opportunity
okay good dog hear that [ __ ] here the
how long should I bet like because I did
this now like [ __ ] somber you're
gonna be coming in I am a well woman now
this is this is my new won't big long
there's a few things we need for this
book um well I guess I know the option
okay um reduce my hands sure okay before
use the [ __ ] hammer let me try this
thing yeah I well sociopathic get get
get dad Cat Cat Cat gun can't judge good
you gotta be [ __ ] kidding me okay
well Luke has more to say I guess where
Sarah's got her foot he doesn't need to
be a part of it
oh [ __ ] anything else in here now
yeah I heard people talking I would
learn that move until certain there's a
[ __ ] for I am ok I can Kanda as a
good kid oh oh listen cards you know
anything good in good hands shook Shane
while then shame on them ok ok what's
every year listen the kitchen door
that's good that's good read lesson your
wife is out here by yourself she said
she's out here yeah right whoever she's
with they'll probably come looking for
great they show up we got her a shed hey
back at us Betsy now that's some [ __ ] I
don't want to get into I'm just so look
Tina anything over here yeah I guess
that's for this fish and let the
grown-ups talking out let's just get the
[ __ ] cleaned good good good
and that dogs in this place we [ __ ] up
[ __ ] I mr. nut jobs play for the quacks
not [ __ ] I hate those things like
feather deemed it doc sucks black has
gone out here yep he guesses could have
been a win an entrance i coulda came in
through now and he i could kid kid and i
am such a little Slough you know I'm not
gonna eggs at Jesus get the [ __ ] out of
my face let me get some real stuff done
here yay I here yay as [ __ ]
can I hear me
bedroom bathroom that's where it shits
got to be right proc side and bandages
hopes no one's on the [ __ ]
we can under the shower real quick oh
good god is empty I like empty bathrooms
ok let's open this medicine cabinet okay
we got a needle which is what we need
ding thank you clean yeah okay the
[ __ ] I still need some bandages and
something to keep it from getting
infected hmm bandages bandages they have
to have medical supplies around here
somewhere um okay
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] you been a hot girl yeah
[ __ ] high oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh she is
prego she's [ __ ] she knows baby bring
the bathtub let it be okay oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] we got shader here it's just that
good because yesterday she has to die
sorry guys if you I've gotten keen to
her but as you can tell I don't like her
she has to go for the survival of
species you know ok I would get the [ __ ]
out of here I think you did [ __ ] cuz i
would hate that stinky [ __ ] smell
[ __ ] McGee adheres anyone no no now's ok
good you're not supposed to be in here
he helped me hi can you please help me
I'm not supposed to talk to you my dad
can't now okay huh help me and I'm gonna
tell him I I'm hurt please help me oh I
shouldn't miss fetch what happens you
the doctor made me carry her yeah that's
your finance you want to see it it
really wasn't one of them it really
wasn't okay
you grow dead yet you have to be Imogen
what my dad says yeah I know help me I
need something to clean it up and
something to wrap it with a clean
bandage my dad says were out of real
bandages but I know where to get
something to claim it that's what this
applies ok good I'll help you good thank
you I don't era hi Sarah I'm Clementine
ah we're friends right we can be best
friend I haven't been another for my
absence way before she's a girl Todd I
am buck is ok but she's and that's it
yes we are friends promise it's
important friends have to trust each
other no matter what I promise this is
gonna be tough
oh it's gonna bite you she's [ __ ]
green a close match I'm gonna turn on
you if I need a better is she crazy she
still thinking about way [ __ ] out of
here that'll work you can't do here
though lemon will find you don't worry I
won't [ __ ] thanks Sarah oh [ __ ] where I
supposed to do it she's on the bandage
isn't ok
who I don't know if I want to go on and
a choice all right he ain't out of jail
was I'm going to [ __ ] blank art
downstairs Cara my wounds just take this
[ __ ] [ __ ] bed shits you know it's
take this [ __ ] [ __ ] bed sheets
okay Oh Rex not exactly bandages but
they should help stop the bleeding Lucy
you think an iPad or something I can
take you know son line right backing out
back now I'm getting [ __ ] trouble for
y'all [ __ ]
I'm going to get the [ __ ] out of here
poof oh no please don't let them be down
there oh [ __ ] my way [ __ ] my brown ass
hole thank God well thanks it may get
the [ __ ] out of here
[ __ ] and [ __ ] tore this place up she
is not doing too good now this is gonna
be the crazy but Gucci like ouchie
hometeam people break anything okay this
is gonna [ __ ] suck never oh oh my god
that's crazy okay let me clean this
[ __ ] first okay get get as you stop
that [ __ ] all over baby yeah baby uh
yeah I get back at one way to die ah
babe I gotta use that [ __ ] rice okay
okay I'm good I'm fine now the fun part
anything nice to me worms now get kid
again i'm glad that happen above it take
this nate us in here
ah [ __ ]
this is gonna suck [ __ ] huge just how
krista should me krista shine can't move
earth happened like my back out [ __ ]
hey I'm yonder you don't think um PP uh
I know oh yeah just like taking a big
[ __ ] okay okay okay what's like a chef
there a good guy okay not good got it
gotcha yes yes I'm not backing out man
and I like okay okay cool very fast
she's like I don't like this game yea
though i condemned the unlocked and
landing I'm bummed though oh yeah I care
one last one last one come baby come on
baby MX counts cold but I am in the
lower you go to me when we were there Oh
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
[ __ ] Savage oh I have a little boy oh
yah oh yah oh yah oh yah oh yah yah yah
owe me money can be named let's look at
this I'm like at a work in progress I
get enough baby yeah yeah get enough
baby clean the chip clean a chit oh yeah
so with my life or tomorrow [ __ ] what is
this about ok I should really get better
ok
okay up for the handbags after that yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeahs to some
East oh you know okay go good oh yeah
it's right in the face now let's get a
hammer I guess okay good good good good
now let's get this i guess and what's
just key and strike them you know I oh
yeah good yeah let's play some Q action
you know it's just a cute action okay
yep good God now let's give this ham
where I guess and that's just like let's
just make this simple I used to make
this fun and I like okay and I like make
sure we appreciate it okay make sure
last yeah make sure how it work pays off
you know I should be anything you want
to life back at how the hell didn't get
in here little girls tell his nails are
you all right still not bitten I never
was and you left me out here to die you
patched yourself up yeah a cheap deal
from us this doesn't change a thing she
hasn't done anything there's the man not
caring up mate you left me no choice you
could have just left relax Rebecca bring
her in and I'll take a look at her arm
thanks and he's sneaking around
you better get inside you hungry yeah if
I can read along gay ok give me a
[ __ ] choice is fine
this might hurt a little how she left
there suturing skills need some work but
otherwise I say she should be fine eyes
off I hope it wasn't a lurker bite it
was the fever would have already set in
and a temperature would be through the
roof okay Jay's toughly Santa bandages
second I was sure you have done what you
did what still what do you mean you
manipulated my daughter shed for her
help she's not someone you can just ask
for help she's a second half of you the
benefit of the doubt but there are a few
things you need to know about my
daughter okay she isn't like you you may
not get that initially but once you're
around her for a while you'll understand
she knew how bad the world is was really
like out there she passed a function
okay she's my little girl she's all I
have left and I would ask did you stay
away from her
I'm sorry I didn't know it's okay you're
forgiven just don't make any more
mistakes okay now i gotta cut her off I
gotta cut that [ __ ] off when I say good
to [ __ ] away hurry oh good good hello
yeah like that gays I like that gays
yeah yeah bout you some food if you're
hungry ya better be something cat
that's going to lead one hell of a star
he bet your ass or what else going
pretty badass it doesn't bother me I can
live with it Wow nice yes sicknasty oh
you think [ __ ] like porridge this
[ __ ] is that Mod Podge or anything look
I just want to say I'm sorry for for
being a dick up there okay got kind of
aggro that was definitely not cool like
as I growl Nick's been known to go off
every once in a while don't hold it
against him okay I guess we all have our
moments you definitely had one out there
you were just protecting your friends I
get it I mean be so harsh I just we had
a bad experience once
what happened Macbeth she cut off my
deck Nick lost his dog we took care of
someone who got bit it was my fault it
was no one's fault are they gonna cast
we thought we could control it but we
couldn't and then she turned in his mom
was standing right there she got a cat
okay good there was nothing we could do
about okay anyway hopefully you
understand ah I do yeah hey
back to my [ __ ] red dish oh yeah
that's great since you're pretty much on
your own mr. plan I don't know I'm kind
of on my own now well you're welcome to
stay here if you want okay you let
yourself heal up take some time to sort
things out ok ok guys get do you think
everyone else will be ok with it I'll
just have to deal with it ok dad kept so
what happened to your parents oh you
don't mind they died and then I ended up
eating he would view it out of my life
into them what happened is just about
everyone's parents just so young didn't
think he could make on your own for so
long but maybe he did he died that's
tough that shit's called I lost my folks
too ok ok I didn't ask but thanks i yes
sorry I shouldn't yeah you shouldn't
it's up my parents went on vacation and
love me with a babysitter and they never
came back that's like that we link to
Savannah to find them but they were
already dead
well I'm sorry to hear that and that I
ate here meet this man found me and took
care of me he met up with other
survivors we all tried to make it but it
didn't work his name was Lee he taught
me how to survive he told me to stay
away from cities what happened to him um
lai lai what happened that the same
thing that happens to everyone but he
saved me first lots of times no sounds
like he was a real good guy yeah he was
that she thinking it'll be the new Leigh
you better get the [ __ ] out of my finish
hey dinner up but I'm out there stand
and watch and I can't help but notice
this place is lit up like a goddamn
beacon in the middle of the woods yeah
it's time to turn in anyways I'll get
your winks while you can because we're
going fishing at first light temple
fresh brookies for dinner wouldn't that
be nice yes yes ah that's weird okay
that's cool hey you know oh you're still
here mmm yeah [ __ ] I'll push you down
the stairs on till Paula coat hangers
you just saw it hey Jess white [ __ ] how
wouldn't be comfortable if I were you
[ __ ] this [ __ ] out that's for sure
whose baby is it oh [ __ ] excuse me
that's sad it's not alvis whose is it
you [ __ ] know well I'm gonna [ __ ] her
out you should probably think about
being nicer to me oh yes I'm gonna [ __ ]
her up that's just my advice oh oh yeah
I've all of them is you're going to be a
good kid you've not what you came here
for now go I'm gonna [ __ ] you up [ __ ] I
wanna push you down the stairs and I
would I yeah yeah it is i'm gonna push
you down and i would jump on you and I'm
gonna pay you back up and ride you down
like a like a coat
how you holding up I heard you got an
earful from Rebecca less Oh as always
once she gets going there's no bringing
her back her barks worse than her what's
her problem crazy bringing a baby into a
world like this how could you fit door
could use of the door how far are these
fish traps it ain't much further like
again anyone teach you how to shoot yeah
that I mean taught proper any idiot with
a finger can shoot yeah but not a rifle
well that makes sense let's kick this
thing it probably knock you on your ass
oh that's way those boy with a 6
millimeter in my hands about your age
first time I took him up came across
this beautiful 13 point buck just
standing there on the ridgeline the boy
takes the rifle he lines up the shot
just like I taught him and then I hear
him start whining he turns to me and
says I can't do it I can't shoot at
Uncle Pete please don't make me shoot it
really no way hey why didn't you wait
you want us standing around while you
piss on a tree you know where the river
is boy anything so I grabbed the gun out
of his hand before the big buck runs off
when bang the gun fires boy nearly
gutshot V and of course the buck gets
away what are you going and telling her
this [ __ ] for cuz you almost blew her
face off yesterday seems relevant trying
to allow it's nothing personal with you
are you always giving me a harlot Tess
you're always giving everyone else a
hard time that kept cutting I apologized
already she accepted okay well I didn't
know that it's fine he apologized you're
always trying to embarrass me you're
doing a good enough job of that on your
own I think I kiss oh sorry thank you
really miss her every
Oh bad as well that's a good comeback
though so anyway I found that buck later
that season shot it right in the neck
and I kissed it my sister's figure and
she'd want to freeze some of the meat
Nick didn't speak to me for weeks
sometimes you got to play a role even if
it means people you love hate you for it
you should tell them that maybe I'm
afraid that my feeling friendly
retributive not reciprocity Mia ok Nick
Jesus variant juice and get let's say oh
ok ok ok there's a summer party like I'm
gone haywire that [ __ ] is dead who do
you think did this the crows not sure
yet but it ain't your average gang of
thugs that much I know think about it
your Carver what do you do whose Carver
check those guys there [ __ ] his car be
careful some of them might still be
moving
and what can I do see if you can find
anything else like what a toothbrush
like what might tell us who did this
hell I'm
that [ __ ] this one's shocked too through
the head yeah yeah check the rest and
look for ammo we're running low I think
off to the side here sometimes refer
goodies though can I help I got it are
you sure you're okay ask my uncle he
knows everything yeah [ __ ] I said I got
it okay I said I got it okay one more
time I said I got it okay not Jesus well
[ __ ] dick hole that's not breasts are
out there this was no rinky-dink pissing
match what are you pissing mitch's I'm
gonna join fooball where you going huh
kusoo bar [ __ ] out of here gotta check
the rest what why calm down and think
about it son oh you gotta get out of
here now Jesus Christ get a hold of
yourself what if someone's alive Nick
who cares cuz they might just be
inclined to tell us who did this we
gotta do this now this guy's neck
[ __ ] stay here keep searching these
this is a dumb idea you know Nick I
don't like this either but sooner or
later you're gonna have to realize a
simple truth what it's you're an [ __ ]
that nobody in this world is ever gonna
give a goddamn whether you like
something wrong that is [ __ ] that gotta
grow up son whatever come on plan you
want to be useful keep a lookout on that
tree line okay whoever did this might
still be out there waiting for another
sucker to stumble across this mess just
like baton of fish I'm on it you always
so agreeable no good you'll fit right
into this
yeah dad look just keep your house oh
hope this isn't i don't i'm not friends
with other people so it's fine damn it
more on that side you check out these
ones see if there's anything on them
that'll tell us who they were okay ah
this guy that's when Chris asked people
oh oh [ __ ] is that Krista who's this guy
looks like that you know where that fish
is
ok
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] are going to get that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] alive on your bed what
happened to you ah yeah Krista the woman
I was with what happened to her please
tell me tell me tell me sir
should I give him water give the water
come on let's just find it what happenin
hey I'm fine I'm fine just just lost my
footing oh yeah markers about ammo come
this way [ __ ] damn it you get your
asses over here fault over you I gotta
find out what happened to that price you
gotta get out of here get over here god
damn it can't you listen to me once just
one time of goddamn oh listen to me
dammit see you lay out I'll cover you
okay good good the best way I'm going to
be in this group is if I next start yeah
[ __ ] hey now it's good on the other
side its shadow
oh [ __ ] mr. limpy over there well I'm
glad I gave him the water because if he
survives he's gonna be good Taylor what
are you gonna do great that's out fine
someone came here looking for you a man
What did he say what his name was oh
damn well who it was who is he now the
guys we were with before Harvard what's
he gonna do I can't keep going I figure
we got about four or five more days to
reach Hills mountains we ain't here to
rob nobody just relax and put the gun
down oh [ __ ]
it's a dude you were dead oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] all right thank you guys um
just trying to save Krista oh good no
way did he kill a dog yes yes except yes
yes I do you for water thing man hello
people didn't show you this did you say
Niger p that good alright guys will I
thank you for that you're watching this
episode you know like more to come here
yeah alright alright adios be jazz